A bridge that makes unusual noises.
A movie that has been banned from being shown in North America.
And then we travel to Brussels to meet a man who had a close encounter with an alien surveyor.
But things get really weird when the alien walks away today on Dead Rabbit Radio.
[Demonic music]
Hey everyone, welcome back to another episode of Dead Rabbit Radio.
I'm your host Jason Carpenter.
I'm having a great day.
I hope you guys are having a great day too.
We got a lot of stuff to cover today.
So let's hop on board the Jason Jalopy.
[Demonic music]
That's a great acre song.
Is there an old television show involving a junkie car?
Beverly Hillbilly is the one I was looking for.
How does that song go?
[Demonic music]
That is my non-copyrighted version of the Beverly Hillbilly song.
So we're all hopping on board.
I got my banjo.
I'm sitting in the back.
You guys get to drive the Jason Jalopy today.
[Demonic music]
Hurry up Jason.
Just do the stupid episode.
Hold on, I gotta do my solo.
Jason, the whole thing's been a solo.
I'm fine.
I'll put my banjo away.
You go, where are we going?
And I say, we are going to Heartbreak Bridge.
You're like, Jason, it's still not enough info.
Just use the GPS.
[Demonic music]
And as you try to figure out how to use my old GPS,
you're finally able to find out that we're headed
to the town of Portal, Nebraska.
The car is going down the road.
[Demonic music]
Sun setting.
That's it for the episode.
See you guys later.
Now, so anyways, we end up in Portal, Nebraska.
[Demonic music]
We're going around the corner of the music sites up again.
Your ears are bleeding at this point.
You're like, huh?
I tell you, my doctor says I have to play this
if I stop playing.
My heart stops.
And you don't believe me entirely,
but at the same time, you're a little unsure.
So, boom, boom, boom, boom.
But eventually I do, I'm going to put the banjo on my back.
We're going to walk around Portal, Nebraska.
Now, Portal is kind of an odd ghost town.
From what I can gather, it is a town
that is now surrounded by the suburbs.
So it was basically like there was a railroad track there,
a post office, a little town built around the post office,
and then everything kind of shut down.
But the buildings are still there,
but then there's just suburbs around it.
So it's like an old schoolhouse, an old post office,
a train stop, maybe a couple other buildings,
and then there's a great grass yard,
and then there's Lil Billy's house,
where he just hangs out, throws baseballs at people.
So it's not like a traditional ghost town
in the middle of nowhere type of thing.
A town has popped up around this place.
And for all I know, the buildings aren't there anymore.
It was kind of hard to tell.
This place is in Wikipedia.
It's a legit place.
But this is pretty much the entire sentence
in the Wikipedia page.
"Portal was established on the railroad.
"A post office opened at portal in 1887
"and remained in operation until it was discontinued in 1898."
That's pretty much it.
So why are you wasting my time with this, Jason?
Why did you drag us all the way out to portal?
If that's all there is.
Wikipedia, if that's all there is,
is there really a story here?
And I go, "Yes, yes, I wanna waste your time."
Would I?
And then you go, "Jason, did you listen
"to last Friday's episode?"
And I was like, "Okay, so let's talk about portal Nebraska."
So in the early 1900s, there was the school there,
little school there, and at the school was a teacher.
Can you have a school without a teacher?
That is a question you should ask a philosopher.
Or 20 years from now when all teachers
have been replaced with robots.
But can a school exist without a teacher?
As of now, no.
And especially not back then.
So you had a teacher and she was coming to class
and she's like, "Students, today we're going to learn
"about history.
"It's happening right now 'cause it's the 1900s."
So open your books and the kids are like doing schoolwork
and then she'd go home and she'd eat soup, home alone,
doing stuff, burglars trying to break in her house.
She's like, "Ah, electrocuting them."
The next day she comes to school,
she's like, "We're gonna learn more about math today.
"It's the new fangled science, math, it just invented."
So these little 1900 kids, there's not 1900 kids
in the 1900s kids, they're reading the books,
learning about math first time ever.
She goes home, it's home alone too.
Now different burglars are trying to break in her house
or maybe the same ones, I don't know,
I never saw any of those movies.
But the stress gets to her.
Whether it was the constant break-ins at her home
or maybe it was the fact that she had to wear
really, really chafy, old-timey clothing
'cause that stuff doesn't look very comfortable.
It looks thick and woolen and just kind of gross.
It'd be like wearing a wool sweater
but all over your body.
She eventually snaps, so she's in class one day
and she's like, "Kids, you wanna learn a real lesson?
"You wanna learn how I got these scars?"
Apparently she became a joker.
She has a mental breakdown.
She barricades the door, she grabs a hatchet,
which she apparently has in her classroom.
You know, in case a bear comes lumbering through,
there's three little bears standing on top of each other
wearing a trench coat and a human face.
Wait, no, they wouldn't wanna be human sized.
They were supposed to be kids.
The little bear cubs would be sneaking in
with little human masks.
She has the hatchet to chase them up.
This teacher has a hatchet in her classroom.
She barricades the door, shut.
She jumps up on her desk, starts swinging the hatchet
over her head, that's not part of the myth,
but we're just gonna add it in.
And she proceeds to cut off all the kids' heads.
(imitates
the head)
So what do you do when you feel bad after a mass murder?
You cut their hearts out and walk to the bridge
and throw their hearts one by one into the water.
That is the story, that's the origin story
of what's known as Heartbeat Bridge.
Heartbeat Bridge.
And the legend today, they say,
if you go to Portal Nebraska,
if you go to this little tiny parcel of land,
you can walk across Heartbeat Bridge
and you can hear the sounds of heartbeats.
Now that could be a bullfrog.
Could be a bullfrog living underneath the bridge,
but supposedly it's the sound of the hearts.
And sometimes the ghost teacher will show up
on the bridge as well, mourning the loss of all of her students.
This story obviously has some huge holes,
and I'm not talking about the holes in the children's chest.
And the reason why I was able to make all those jokes
about kids getting their heads chopped off,
because the story's not true.
There's no historical reference of a mass murder
taking place at a school.
But Jason, it happened in the 1900s
and they weren't writing stuff down.
Trust me, they didn't have the best record keeping,
but they would write down,
"School Marm Kills 12, Throws Hearts in River."
Like, they had very good records dating all the way back
to like the 1500s, 1600s.
So early 1900s definitely would have been in the newspaper.
So it didn't happen at all.
So I feel totally fine making all those jokes.
There's a couple other questions about it.
One, nobody knows where this bridge is at now.
Like, it's weird.
It's an urban legend in the area,
but when people go,
there's disagreement over which bridge it is.
Which to me, it should be pretty obvious.
It's the bridge adjacent to the schoolhouse
where the kids got murdered,
and the bridge where you hear human hearts
beating underneath it.
It's not an easy thing to confuse.
You're at another bridge across town.
You're like, "That's weird.
I don't hear the tortured souls of a bunch of kids,
but this might be it."
Like, it's either the bridge that has the phenomenon
that's in the area, or it doesn't exist.
So there's disagreement over which bridge is heartbeat bridge,
but the bridge supposedly has that horrible sound
and a ghost.
Most important question is, women, okay.
Let me say this.
Like, looking at like movies and stuff like that,
women in the 1900s,
despite their clothes looking very uncomfortable,
tended to be, at least in the movies, pretty attractive.
Would you bang a school marmed ghost?
Because, hold on, before you shut off the podcast,
let me make my argument.
On the one hand, you would say no,
because she's probably going to be like super snooty,
and she can hit you with a ruler,
and I'm not into that type of stuff.
Well, I am into snooty girls.
I'm into real snatching the other thing.
That's it.
We're putting that.
She'll hit you with a ruler,
and she's a ghost.
Those are the two downsides to her being,
banging her, right?
But the plus side is she's super snooty,
and I love like real bitchy chicks.
Girls who are like snooty or like bitchy and stuff like that.
I love that.
So you get that,
'cause she's a school marmer in the 1900s,
and she's hot,
'cause she's the school marmer from the 1900s.
Would you try seducing her?
Now, to be fair, you might have a hard time
picking up a ghost at the site of her mass murder,
'cause if that's the only place she manifests,
it's not like you could then see her at the library,
or see her at a bar,
and be like, "Hey, I read about you in the paper.
"A horrible thing that happened,
"but I've lost my temper too.
"Never murdered anybody, but I've been there.
"Can I buy you a drink?"
And she'd be like, "Yes, yes, thank you."
And you can get her mind off of it.
You're sitting at the bar,
all of a sudden some funny television show comes on,
you're sitting watching it together,
close captioning 'cause everyone's talking,
you're drinking, you're having a good time,
and then you invite her back to your place.
That is what I do, generally,
but because she's a ghost,
she's trapped at the site.
Okay, so let's rephrase this here.
There's a hot girl, she's sitting on a bridge,
where she, 100 years ago, murdered a bunch of kids
through their hearts, through their hearts underwater.
And I show up, I'm like, "Hey, what's up?"
"Hey, how's it going?"
"Yeah, my name's Jason, it's nice to meet you."
And she's like, "Ah, yeah,
"and she probably gets hit on all the time."
And I know, but I gotta keep going for this, right?
Like, this is what I want.
You don't let up first time, the girl kind of shrugs,
'cause I get that a lot.
Kind of shrugs, kind of the shoulder look,
but I just go, "She's just being snooty."
So now this has become how Jason picks up women of a certain.
The, you don't give up the first time,
unless they, I've had girls say I'm not interested,
and to me, that's the best,
'cause then I don't have to waste my time.
They'll just be like, "No, I'm not interested."
And I'm like, "Okay, I'm out."
But, and I appreciate that.
But, I'm like, you know, and I don't walk away first.
I'm like, "Well, you know,
"beautiful night out, isn't it?"
And she's kind of like, "Yeah, it is really nice."
And then I usually will find some of this,
another tip I do, I will find somebody else in the vicinity
to make fun of, that I think that person wouldn't like.
So let's see me in this,
definitely has become what Jason picks up women of a certain.
I meet a girl at a bar,
and let's say there's a bad karaoke singer
or something like that, I'll be like, "Oh my God."
Like, I guess I'll make a joke.
I'm not gonna repeat one of the jokes I'll make
on this episode, 'cause they're usually really bad,
but girls tend to find them funny.
And so, as we're sitting on this heartbeat bridge,
as we're sitting on heartbeat bridge,
I see a guy jogging in the distance.
And I'm like, "Oh, look at that guy.
"Make a funny joke about what he's wearing
"or something like that."
And then she starts laughing,
and then I'm hitting on her.
The whole time we're hearing,
"Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom."
It's the heartbeats.
I'm trying to mack on this girl over the heartbeats
of her dead murder victims.
But I would still probably try it.
I probably would still try it,
because I'm just that kind of guy.
But I don't remember what my hypothetical question was.
I don't remember if it's if you should
or should you hit on a ghost?
Or should I hit on a ghost?
Or I don't remember what the hypothetical was.
The point is, the story is 100% not true.
It's an interesting, creepy story
that I'm sure was passed around the neighborhood
for a long time,
because there was a creepy schoolhouse in the area
that was abandoned.
And some big brother made this story up,
and it spread through the neighborhood
to the point that now it's an internet legend.
But no, no one was murdered here.
And the idea of noises being heard
underneath bridges is very, very common.
There's been stories of the Supicide Dog Bridge
and Dublin or Britain or something like that.
They see a misty figure kind of walking along the bridge.
It's not uncommon to see mist around bridges.
It's not uncommon as water is moving underneath stuff
to make odd noises.
So there probably is a bridge in the area
or a bridge somewhere in the world
that sounds like there's heartbeats
because of the way the water's shading the rocks.
But this story definitely didn't happen.
It's an interesting urban legend.
And I totally would try to pick this chick up.
But, but I don't know if I'd bring her home
because I already have a haunted doll
and an old man in the closet.
I don't know, I'd have to say, how about your place?
And she's like, yeah, sure.
And then we go into a hellish void.
I'm like, ah!
Still, it's, I mean, you know,
bad ghost sex is better than no ghost sex.
Let's go ahead and move on to our next story
that to be honest, I'm gonna have to cut a bunch out of
because I went off in that rant.
This is a story of a movie
that's actually lost media in a sense.
Lost media is the idea of,
it's kind of exactly what it sounds like.
So you have stuff that was filmed
and then is disappeared or recorded and it's disappeared.
And now some of the lost media is like Grizzly Man.
It's a guy who really loved Grizzly Bears,
him and his girlfriend in a tent.
And there's an audio recording of them being eaten alive
or at least disemboweled by a bear.
The camera was on, but the lens cap was on as well.
So you hear this audio.
That's considered a lost media.
There's maybe been 10 people who've listened to it.
Christine Chubbock's suicide video,
she was a newscaster who said,
"I'm gonna try to commit."
Now for the latest in "Blood and Gore,"
here's a news first in attempted suicide.
She shoots herself on live television in the 1970s.
So there was like one VCR in the nation that recorded it.
These things are considered lost media
'cause for the most part it's all gone.
This is an interesting and more lighthearted version of that.
I found some more lighthearted lost media
that I'm gonna profile
'cause I find the idea of stuff disappearing fascinating.
Like there's a lot of old "Doctor Who" episodes
that were lost at the time
because people when they were being made,
they're like, "Oh, this is just a stupid show for kids."
Or this is just a bunch of nerds.
We'll just shoot the show.
No one will ever wanna watch it again.
And so they were like re-recording over tapes.
So it wasn't just "Doctor Who,"
but a lot of shows did that.
But what happened with "Doctor Who" was some fan
was recording it way back in the day
with this very first VCR.
So they were able to reconstruct a lot of old episodes
and they found episodes in the BBC archives
and stuff like that.
So anyways, this one though is basically lost media
only in North America.
You can watch it on YouTube,
but you can't show it to anybody else.
You cannot, it cannot be commercially shown
in the United States or Canada
because of a lawsuit with two of their actors.
This movie is called "Don's Plum."
And I watched it in preparation for this story.
I don't like dramas.
The first 10 minutes is really irritating
'cause I hate jazz music.
I can't stand it.
I cannot stand jazz music.
And people go, "Dude, you're a big hip-hop fan.
You love rap."
Jazz is the beginning of rap.
Yeah, I love human women and humans evolved
from protozoas coming out of the ocean.
I don't love protozoas.
Like, I get it that jazz may have influenced
the music I listen to, but jazz sucks.
It's the worst music out there.
I hate it.
I'd rather listen to "Honky Tonk Country" than jazz.
And I despise "Honky Tonk Country."
I don't like jazz.
So when the movie started off at a jazz club,
it already was two beats behind.
But they leave the jazz club
into some of the worst jazz music too.
(singing)
I'm coming.
He's not coming.
But it's like, (singing)
This is a musical episode, apparently.
Jazz is coming and it's making you feel good, girls.
You know how I make you feel.
Make you feel like you're the only one in the world, girls.
Oh my God, dude.
I was like, I'm only watching this movie
so I can do a segment on it.
They leave the jazz club.
The whole movie is basically these characters
sitting at a Denny's-esque restaurant called Don's Plum.
Maybe it's supposed to be a fancier restaurant
but it reminded me of a Denny's with the kind of the seating.
There's four guys and they each have to bring a girl.
Each weekend they bring a different girl to this place.
They sit around, they talk.
It is one of the most authentic movies like that
I've seen in a long time.
'Cause I used to do that.
I used to go, "Hang out with my friends."
We'd all show up, we'd go to a Denny's,
we'd sit around and talk.
Sometimes we'd talk about normal stuff.
Sometimes a fight would break out.
Sometimes someone would bring a girl.
We didn't bring a different girl each weekend
but sometimes somebody would bring a girl
that nobody knew and she started Mouthing Off
and the confrontation starts.
Or sometimes one of the dudes would start Mouthing Off.
Confrontation starts.
So it's very, very realistic movie.
A very, very well done movie.
The problem is, is it strength.
Is you have an actor.
All four actors were fairly well known at the time
and a lot of them have gone on to do certain things.
But one of the actors, I don't remember,
we had the actor who was in "Antiraj."
You're like, "Jesus, that doesn't help me."
There's one jacket, it was an "Antiraj."
There's a bunch of people, I don't remember.
Anyways, there was a guy from "Antiraj."
But then Toby McGuire and Leonard, Leonard,
Toby McGuire and Leonardo DiCaprio.
Leonard DiCaprio is these more commonly known as,
are in this movie as well.
This was before "Titanic."
This was before "The Cider House Rules."
It's basically total, it's almost all improv.
It's very, very, it's almost all ad-libbed
and it's really off the cuff.
So they make this movie, which apparently was a rid,
there's a lot of disagreements on what was going on.
But anyways, this movie is made and Toby McGuire
and/or his agent is like, "Shut it down.
"You can't let this movie get released.
"You look like a jerk."
And he does look pretty bad,
but Leonard DiCaprio looks like a psychopath in this movie.
And again, very, very real.
I don't think he's a psychopath,
but he comes off as a very, very irritating jerk in it
and he does a great job doing it.
And that may have been him,
that may be him now,
that may have been him when he was younger.
It could have been acting,
it could have been a little bit of everything put together,
but apparently he thought it was great.
Toby McGuire's people thought it was garbage
and they didn't want to get released before, you know,
Pleasantville and all these movies he was going to do.
'Cause it's very raw.
It's like a drama version of "Clurks."
That type of language and stuff like that.
So Leonard DiCaprio twice threatens to throw a bottle
at a woman's head and that girl was Tara from "Buffy."
So again, you had a lot of young people
before their courage took off.
So what happened was basically eventually,
this is all alleged,
but the producer of the film believes
that Toby McGuire turned Leonard DiCaprio
against the movie as well.
And through various lawsuits,
the way it is set up right now is that
the movie cannot be shown commercially
in the United States or Canada.
Eventually the producer of the movie went on
to try to do another,
was basically blackballed from Hollywood,
goes on to do another project in Hollywood,
is told as they're like signing the paperwork,
someone goes, "Oh wait, you're the guy
who was behind Don's Plum."
The guy's name was Dale Wheatley.
The producer's name was Dale Wheatley.
So you get ready to sign another project,
someone goes, "Well, you're the guy
who did Don's Plum, right?"
And Dale's like, "Yeah."
And they're like, "We can't do this deal with you."
He's like, "What are you talking about?"
And the producer who he said was a multi-billion dollar
producer making these huge movies,
the producer goes, "I can't mess with you
because Leonardo DiCaprio will shut me down."
And Dale goes, "You're more powerful
than Leonardo DiCaprio."
And the multi-billion dollar producer's quote was,
"Nobody is more powerful than Leo."
Now, so basically at this point,
the movie is made, you can watch it on YouTube,
but you're not supposed to.
And you can see it overseas,
but I mean the movie at this point
is like 20 years old as well,
but you got a movie starring two
of the biggest actors, soon to be actors at that time.
Leonardo DiCaprio is still a powerhouse,
Tomy McGuire is still an A-list star.
The funniest footnote to the story is, yes, it's lost media.
Until the internet popped up,
it was really hard to find a copy of this.
Lars Vontriere, the director who does not care
about anything, held a film festival
just to show the movie.
He didn't show it in America.
He's not gonna get fined or arrested,
but he did have a film festival
and he showed the movie over there.
And he basically is the,
he's the Kanye West of filmmaking.
And Kanye West is the penultimate rock star right now.
And that's Lars Vontriere.
He just does whatever he wants.
He doesn't care.
I love both of those guys.
But anyway, check out Don's Plum.
It's a fascinating film.
It'll probably make you either really, really mad
that people like these exist
or it'll remind you of your glory days or both.
Yeah, check out Don's Plum.
It is an example of lost media or semi-lost media,
media that was pushed to be lost,
but the producer wouldn't let it go.
And the producer is actually the one
who was pushing to have it online for free,
just so somebody could see the movie he made
with a bunch of his friends back in the days
before lawsuit after lawsuit started.
Let's go ahead and move on to our last story here.
Do I have enough time?
I talked so long about being in ghosts.
Let's see here.
I'm gonna pull an audible
'cause I wanna do that alien story tomorrow.
Let's go ahead.
We're leaving behind the restaurant known as Don.
What restaurants named Don's Plum, anyways?
It's kind of a stupid title for a movie,
stupid title for a restaurant, but it is a well-made movie.
We say goodbye to Don's Plum.
We say goodbye to Leonard de Caprio.
See you later, Leonard.
He's like, "Hey, we're gonna hop in the rabbit rowboat
"and we're going out to sea.
"We're not going to Brussels.
"We're going out to the Atlantic Ocean."
You're like, "That's really specific, Jason.
"Just keep rowing."
(humming)
A wave knocks my banjo out into ocean.
I'm like, "No, banjo."
I turn to you.
I picture you as a banjo now and I'm like,
"Hmm, maybe if I pulled out his veins and his arteries
"and tied them around his ankles,
"I could get the right sort of sound."
You're like, "Jason, you just said that out loud."
I'm like, "Sorry, sorry."
So as I'm still trying to figure out
how to turn you into a human banjo,
we're going back to the year 1917.
The date is September 15th.
And we're gonna sail up and we see a boat on the horizon.
It's called the Zabrina.
And there's a dude named Captain Martin.
His first name is not Captain, but that's weird.
I wonder what his first name was,
'cause he's Captain and his last name is a first name.
I remember once I watched this show,
there was like, "Gidget," it was "Gidget Television" series.
And I learned a valuable lesson on "Gidget" television series.
There was a surfer guy who always dispensed advice
and he said, "Never trust someone with two first names."
And I've always remembered that.
I can't necessarily say it's true.
I don't know why you shouldn't trust someone
with two first names, but whenever you meet someone
whose name is like Stanley Martin,
don't trust someone with two first names.
Captain Martin, though.
He's the captain of the Zabrina.
It's a three-mast schooner.
And it goes port to port in Europe.
So basically this was a time where it was built to,
like, put coal in, and not like a coal,
not like a coal in like a butthole,
but put coal, the burning stuff in.
And you would just go from port to port.
So basically it would move around Europe,
basically like a bus, but on the water.
And it was a flat bottom boat.
It was basically like a giant barge,
but it could also go farther out into the ocean.
I'm assuming other barges can do that too.
So anyways, it would basically go from port to port.
Now it's 1917, so we're in World War I.
Not a good time to be a boat.
There's never a good time to be a boat,
because then you're an inanimate.
Is a boat an inanimate?
You knew this was coming,
for when I said that.
Is a boat an inanimate object?
Not a single thing moves on a boat.
Row boats, sure, you have oars.
But a sail boat is that an inanimate object?
A car is animate 'cause the wheels turn, right?
And a bicycle, same thing.
Is a plane?
And then, I wonder, well now I can't say the word,
but is a plane an inanimate object?
You're like, Jason, you just said you didn't have time.
You spent so much time talking about being in ghost marms.
You had to cut a story off.
Now you're talking about whether or not,
puzzle, puzzle for your brain.
Brain teaser, is a boat an inanimate object.
Anyways, not a good time to be a boat.
In 1917, they're getting blown up.
Captain Martin takes his Sabrina out
on September 15th, 1917.
On September 17th, 1917,
it washes up on a French shore.
(sizzling)
That's not a bunch of explosions.
That's the water hitting the side of the boat
that's sitting on the beach.
The Sabrina was completely empty.
There's nobody on the boat,
which would make sense 'cause it was up on the beach,
but then the question goes, well where are the people?
Now, the Sabrina normally had a six-man crew,
but for this mission, when it was hauling this coal,
had 23 men, all missing.
And people started to ask questions.
They go, why would you need so many more people?
The theory became that the Sabrina
on this particular mission,
most of the time it worked the world's largest slaughterhouse.
Wasn't in there chopping up cows.
It was moving meat all over Europe.
And because it had that flat bottom,
it could go down those narrow rivers.
This time it was moving coal
and it washes up on shore, everyone's disappeared.
The belief was that it was a cue boat,
which was a boat used to haul weapons.
Look like a normal boat, act like a normal boat,
drew no suspicion except for the fact
that it had those sweet, sweet armaments inside its hold.
But that doesn't explain, if it was a cue boat,
it doesn't explain where everybody went.
And after the war, war ends,
good guys win, bad guys lose.
Well, it depends on what you're listening to this episode,
but after the war, people go, hey, you remember that boat?
Like was there this boat, this Sabrina
that was attacked on this particular day
or in these two days?
And the Germans go, no,
we don't have any record of attacking that boat.
We have no record of taking any prisoners war
from that boat.
And I've always find it weird
that people even bother keeping records during war,
but they do.
And they go, we don't have any record of these troops
or these prisoners or anything like that.
This is the theory.
And this is kind of a chilling, creepy story.
So one, you just have possibly a ghost ship.
Ship goes out, aliens suck them all away,
or a ghost shows up and kills them off one by one,
takes them to the hell dimension,
or they go through some sort of remuner triangle
and they travel a thousand years into the future
or 50 years into the past.
That's all well and good and very sci-fi
and very apt for this show.
I think the actual explanation is creepier, to be honest.
This is the working theory.
The Sabrina is going through the water
and a German U-boat, a submarine shows up
and fires a torpedo at it,
passes right underneath the boat
because it's a flat bottom boat.
It's a barge.
Now it looks like a normal boat.
Missile goes, torpedo goes right underneath it.
So at that point, maybe they fire a couple more,
I don't know, the submarine then pulls up to the Sabrina,
boards the ship and takes the crew prisoner.
Now if there were any weapons hidden on the ship,
they could have taken the weapons as well.
'Cause when the ship did wash ashore,
there's no idea of whether or not
there was a bunch of coal found on the boat
or guns found on the boat.
And this is a historical event as well.
The idea is this, that they were captured by the Germans
and you had these 23 men brought onto this German sub.
You had these 23 men brought on the German sub.
But then the sub sinks.
So you have no record of the prisoners being taken.
You have no record of the attack.
Everyone who knows about that attack died in the sub.
I find that honestly creepier.
You imagine you're on a boat.
Let's say you're not hauling weapons.
Let's say you're on this boat
and you get captured by the Germans.
Now you may be a sailor all your life,
but being in one of the first submarines ever used
would be quite different.
So you and your 22 buddies are crammed into an enemy
underwater vessel, still quite alien.
Plains are still flying around
for the first time for crying out loud.
And you've heard of these subs, these U-boats,
but now you're being led into this dark, steamy,
stinky vehicle.
And while you're down there,
you can't wait to get back to your family.
You just wanna get rescued.
If you get sent to a prison camp, that's fine.
Eventually the war will end.
Hopefully you guys will win and you'll go back home.
But then while you're in this vessel,
something goes wrong.
Mismanagement, enemy attack,
your own people trying to attack
what they see as an enemy sub that has you in it,
a torpedo ripping through the hole,
a navigation error crashing into the sea floor.
What have you?
Just two days earlier,
you were a sailor on a barge hauling weapons
or maybe just coal.
And now you're in a vessel at the bottom of the ocean,
surrounded by your friends,
and you are all surrounded by the enemy.
And as water pours into the hole of this strange vehicle,
you can't help think it would have been preferable
had you got whisked into an alien dimension
or met your end of the hand of a vengeful spirit
than to be trapped here in the dark,
in the cold, in the wet coffin
that no one will ever know about.
Your death is a mystery
and no one will ever find out the answer.
DeadRabbitRadio@gmail.com is gonna be our email address.
You can also hit us up at facebook.com/DeadRabbitRadio.
Twitter is @DeadRabbitRadio.
DeadRabbit Radio is the daily paranormal conspiracy
and true crime podcast.
You don't have to listen to it every day,
but I'm glad you listened to it today.
Have a great one, guys.
(upbeat music)